[Music]
hey folks welcome to the Dark Horse
podcast live stream number
158 no need to worry that it might be
only divisible by one in itself that's
not gonna happen here nope yep all of
your concerns are unfounded they were
they were needless I wish I could have
that effort back but oh I didn't mean
your concerns oh you knew at a glance I
did right away yeah just just that good
to to think back to last week's
discussion it's a it's a weak superpower
that one it's a weak super well the
thing is if you're gonna do it just by
checking to see whether it's an even
number you got to be real careful
because you can get tripped up can you
yes very much so I'm not aware of this
you aren't no oh
down in the area of uh two
there is a discussion as to whether two
is prime no I think it's a quest there's
a question about whether or not
zero is prime isn't that right oh no
it's one that's that's the uh the the
confusing one no but I guess I mean
is a is an even prime it's the only yeah
as far as we know I should say that just
to be perfectly careful even though
mathematically there is no reason to be
careful at all
just start out in the weeds this week
decide to do that in the weeds not on
the weed uh no okay not not so uh so
this week we're going to talk a little
bit about a number a wide variety of
things
um
and maybe instead of trying to figure
out how those all go together in advance
uh just just wait for it but let's do
the top of the hour stuff yeah first
mashup
um so you can find us on find Dark Horse
on Instagram Facebook LinkedIn and
Twitter at this point we follow these
live streams with a q a you can ask
questions on darkhorsesmissions.com
please consider finding our book
hunter-gatherers guide to 21st century
everywhere books are sold
pretty much yeah uh and if you're
watching on YouTube you can also watch
on Odyssey live that's where the chat is
going on and of course then uh the the
video will also be up on Spotify and the
audio is up you know everywhere you find
podcasts so uh and we know that most of
our audience is listening only so we
have some interesting visuals this week
but we will try to describe them
although it may in a few cases be
difficult to fully defy description they
may defy description yes
yes and we don't have the uh picture
Source how many words ten thousand I
believe that after inflation maybe what
is it what is it I think it's a thousand
it's the usual claim yeah you're I'm
just going orders yeah
for the entire top of the hour okay
okay I will know I will now get out of
the weeds as well
um consider uh finding me where I write
at Natural Selections this last week I
wrote a bit about dominance hierarchies
and gender Norms in humans the week
before I wrote about beavers and their
foundational role in uh in basically
architecting the Landscapes of North
America and the ecosystems of of North
America and yesterday
uh we dropped an episode uh on the same
topic in which you were talking to the
wonderful Jacob Shockey who is a former
student of ours and a friend of ours and
uh you had an almost three hour
conversation almost three hour
conversation and then as you know
um Jacob stuck around and we did some
fun stuff but it turned out there was
just a whole lot of stuff that he had to
say about beavers that uh is gonna have
to wait for a volume two because you
know absolutely there's there's some
very interesting stuff that didn't make
it into the podcast yeah and I haven't
listened to the entire podcast yet I did
read the piece that I wrote on account
of having written it and you know a
couple of the the points that have stuck
with me specifically are
um the mitigating effect on loss of
biodiversity and on extreme weather and
climate conditions like drought and
flood and fire especially in the
American West and then all also the fact
that and I know that you talked about
this in your conversation with Jacob as
well in the Dark Horse podcast that
dropped yesterday but that the the
beaver Trappers were so successful at
what they did and still to this day the
Beavers that remain are very docile so
it's interesting that they that the
beaver trap the Intensive Beaver
trapping over hundreds of years did not
have the selective effect on the
behavior on the personality of beavers
that you might expect that they remain
sort of easy to approach in many regards
but they were effectively eradicated
through so much of the American West
that when the eminent naturalist
Grinnell
came through in the I think it was the
1930s his Natural History notes from his
tour of the American West basically
framed you know put into place an
expectation among ecologists of what of
what we were trying to recover to
which of course is always a dicey
proposition you know aiming aiming for a
single moment in a shifting over both
space and time landscape but he saw
Grinnell saw so so little beavers that
even so few beavers yeah depending on if
it's a collective noun or not
um and you know like us did not infer
from the landscape that what he was
seeing was extraordinary evidence of an
abundance of beavers throughout you know
many many tens of thousands at least of
years the ghost of beavers past yes that
he he said you know he he basically made
a number of claims based on what he saw
but he then made inference that was
wrong and from that we have historical
range maps that are inaccurate because
they're based on this great naturalist
who was normally so good at what he did
but even even he did not see through
basically the fog of time
so I wanted to add one thing to that so
uh probably because beavers were trapped
primarily
um the
REM the remnant of their approachability
might uh not be a strong indicator of
how selected they were by that
interaction and in fact
um well actually this runs a little bit
counter to what I just said but what I
learned from Jacob after the podcast
was that although it has been generally
our experience you're in mine and
generally accepted by most people who
talk about beavers in a scientific
context
that they are nocturnal that there's
actually good reason to think that that
is a switch that they have moved into a
nocturnal Niche presumably to avoid
people
um and that the evidence for this which
is because Trappers are lazy or because
not all Brokers go nocturnal at once and
so you know you you evade the Trappers
yeah but also just because we're diurnal
and so we're not as good at hunting at
night
um so anyway you hobble lazy for good
reason yeah right lazy as a matter of
self-preservation in large measure but
um but the lack of the tapedum lucidum
in the eye that is the reflective
surface that causes nocturnal animals
eyes to shine if you ever shine a
flashlight at a dog at night you see the
eyes shine back that absence suggests
that this was not in initially
um a nocturnal creature and it's
interesting I know another story where a
creature has
um
moved into
diurnality by the same mechanism which
is a very strange way for the same
reason for the same reason and this is
um the one and only example of a bat
that is diurnal that bat appears to have
been nocturnal in origin but it is
hunted by people in the roost and so it
pays to be out when people are up doing
their hunting so just this is a macro or
Mega whatever mega mega character so
this is one of the like flying foxes
this is one of these big beefy bats that
actually would provide you know
sustenance for a family of humans as
opposed to these little micro bits that
we've got here in the new world more of
a snack bat yeah this is a full meal bat
all right I take it back but in any case
interesting that uh beavers do appear to
have been modified in this way and it
hasn't seemed it hasn't changed their
approachability so much but it has
changed the likelihood of an encounter
based on them being primarily nocturnal
although I will say
at least
two of the instances in which I've seen
beavers it was during the day right
um one in Oaks bottom down in Portland
and one you and I saw a beaver I want to
say Eastern Washington somewhere yeah it
was it was in the Cascades uh very
interesting animal that we get we got to
watch quite a bit I was also reminded of
a
um that's funny uh I found Jacob during
the podcast talked a little bit about
the fact that his first encounter with a
beaver had been at the bus stop at the
loop at Evergreen that one had trundled
by and we had both remarked he'd never
seen a beaver before that I don't think
so even though he interesting even given
where he grew up that's interesting and
uh anyway his point was he should have
followed it because what the hell was it
doing there there's no obvious reason
for a beaver to be there and then as I
was falling asleep last night I realized
that there was a there was a an episode
in my teaching at every cream or I
didn't see a beaver but I was biking
along the bike path on the main road
there
and I saw a beaver sign right I saw a
place where beavers had chewed some
sticks and it's in a little Culvert
right no place that a beaver could
possibly hope to create any kind of
useful uh Pond and I had I had brought
my students and my co-faculty there and
they disbelieved me that it was real and
so anyway Jacob's observation of a
beaver you know what would be a block
and a half from where I found Beaver
sign is
um interesting there for whatever reason
they're active up on the road there yeah
no and I actually think
no one else will know the particular
geography of the area around Evergreen
but yeah I actually am remembering areas
that now now that I think on it feel
feel beautiful to me yeah and in fact
there is one uh across that road
um there's a there is a wetland that is
otherwise inexplicable yeah that's it
uh so so check both of those things out
check out uh the podcast uh the Dark
Horse podcast from yesterday and uh my
Natural Selections piece from two weeks
ago and uh will continue hopefully we'll
have Jacob back and um and we'll
continue talking about this
okay
um still top the hour stuff our new
store is darkhorsestore.org you can get
uh merch with Lightwood Tyrant uh epic
tabbies uh direwolves Dark Horses lots
of good stuff lots of good stuff there
and finally we are supported by you our
audience we appreciate you subscribing
liking sharing with our full episodes
here on YouTube and odyssey or Spotify
or Clips at Dark Horse podcast Clips
another Odyssey or YouTube and uh
YouTube has begun running ads on her
stuff again even though they fully
debonetized us so uh this seems like an
illegitimate move as we've mentioned
over and over and over again so you know
they are the only ones seeing benefit
from running ads on our material and so
we appreciate uh even even more than if
they had not done that your support in
any way that you can give it you can
join one of our patreons
where we where you can get access to our
Discord Community they have
um they have conversations ongoing with
people young and old left and right you
know all the demographics you might you
might
um be able to think of and
and you aren't dismissed on account of
having one or more or lacking one or
more demographic markers unlike so many
of the conversations that um seem to be
happening these days so yeah
um I just wanted to say uh
maybe the most important way to support
us is actually spread the word because
one of the ways you know yes they
demonetized us which is a very
aggressive and direct move but then
there's also all of the cryptic stuff
where uh the reach is limited and so you
as a viewer can help us by sharing
things you think are worthwhile with
people who you think aren't seeing them
that's right and then also at our
patreons you can get access to a private
monthly q a online or two uh two
different conversations that Brett has
uh which are on the first Saturday and
Sunday and last Sunday of the month
respectively and I've just reversed the
order so it wasn't respectively and if
you're just listening you have maybe no
idea what I'm talking about and I
apologize for that
um okay so without further Ado we also
have sponsors uh and we we pick and
choose carefully and so you know that if
we are reading a script for a sponsor
that we actually
um we actually vouch for that product or
um or service
um either in practice or in theory okay
our first sponsor this week is missing
and Main which doesn't make anything
that I could use but it makes beautiful
uncomfortable clothing for men
Brett is wearing them isn't a main shirt
right now uh I don't wear them but Brett
does and frankly ever since he started
he doesn't really want to wear anything
else it seems um but it's great they're
so great I got one for our producer for
Christmas our producer who's also our 18
year old son these shirts look great and
the fabric feels great to the touch and
apparently they're incredibly
comfortable too yes they are yeah and
that's that's one of the big selling
points here is that many men's dress
shirts I hear uh are very stiff and they
sort of restrict your movement a lot but
there's just enough stretch in these
shirts to actually be comfortable to
make you want to wear them as opposed to
have you feeling the entire time you're
wearing them you can't wait to take the
buff most men's dress shirts are badly
tailored and made of material you wish
you'd ever been in contact with not Miz
in a men's shirts they invented the
performance fabric dress shirt they make
the most lightweight breathable and
moisture wicking dress shirt on Earth
they're warm in the winter cool in
summer the kind of product that once you
try it you never go back to Conventional
again and they're machine washable and
even if you're not a dress shirt kind of
guy they've got a whole lot of amazing
flannels pants sweaters and jackets made
from that same missing and made material
that they've become famous for
uh I already said that Brett is wearing
one of several misena main shirts right
now so surprising because they're kind
of your go-to shirts now they're that
good they look great again warm the
winter cool in the summer and so they
work in multiple seasons and climates
which means for instance if you find
yourself traveling from the wintry North
to a more temperate climate in the South
right now you'll be well served by these
wonderful and beautiful shirts as travel
companions
companions so much not to talk to I
don't recommend it I mean you could
stuff them and that they might be better
conversationalists than some but uh but
probably they would you can rest assured
they will they will say nothing that
could constitute misinformation yeah and
you won't feel unsafe in their presence
I expect
that really depends on you I mean yeah
it does yeah yeah yeah I did the bar is
really low actually so
um I would hope that you could manage
not to feel unsafe in the presence of a
shirt uh anyway if you want the best
cold weather or warm weather clothing
check out mizen and Maine right now if
you go to mizzenemain.com and use promo
code Darkhorse you'll receive 20 25 of
any regular price order of 130 or more
that's 25 off when you go to
m-i-z-z-n-a-n-d m a i n.com and use
promo code Darkhorse
okay our second sponsor this week is mud
water
mud water is a coffee alternative made
with four medicinal mushrooms plus herbs
and spices with a seventh of the
caffeine is a cup of coffee you get
energy without the anxiety Jitters or
crash of coffee and it's delicious if
you like the routine of making and
drinking a cup of warmth in the morning
but don't drink coffee or are trying to
cut down try mud water each ingredient
was added with intention it has cacao
and chai lion's mane mushrooms cordyceps
Shaga and reishi turmeric and cinnamon
and more this is a terrific product have
it as a warm drink take it black or with
cream or honey or both and mud water
also makes a non-dairy creamer out of
coconut milk and MCT and it also makes a
sweetener out of coconut palm sugar and
lucuma which is the fruit of an Andean
tree used by the Inca to add you can add
other their non-dairy creamer or their
sweetener if you add if you prefer those
options or mixed mix it up add some of
their coconut milk and MCT creamer with
some honey from your favorite bees or if
you don't have favorite bees from your
favorite beekeeper and if you don't have
a favorite beekeeper consider getting
one but also um eat real honey
the flavor is are you your beekeepers
Keeper in that case
me particularly no no if you get a
favorite beekeeper yeah I guess you I
think you are thinking by definition
yeah your beekeepers keeper yeah
yes the flavor of mud water is warm and
spicy when they have chocolate plus
Masala chai which includes Ginger and
cardamom nutmeg and cloves you can also
blend it into a smoothie with a with
banana and Ice milk or milk like
substance if you don't drink milk mint
and cacao nibs that's my favorite go-to
at the moment it's utterly delicious and
they've got a wonderful new caffeine
free product designed to be a drink for
before bed which is also delightful
mud water is 100 USDA organic non-GMO
gluten-free vegan and kosher certified
mud water allows you to build a morning
ritual to promote sustained energy
without the crash so visit mudwater.com
Darkhorse to support the show and use
cord this code this is different Dark
Horse Mud at checkout for 15 off that's
mudwtr.com Darkhorse and use Dark Horse
Mud at checkout for 15 off
I'm wondering if Eric has a beekeeper
and whether in that case I would be my
brother's beekeepers
keeper I don't know
it's not your brother's beekeeper's
keeper no I'm not but I'm wondering if I
would be if he had a beekeeper and
that's where the uh philosophical never
never under no Circle there's nothing
that could happen that would put me in
that circumstance if you had an
automated beekeeper and he uh gifted it
to me than I think I would be
all right now that we've settled that
yes yes I think you're right I'm now
going to demonstrate what anxiety looks
like because I have not looked at the
script before and it is going to throw
me uh due to dyslexia but here we go our
final sponsor this week is mind Bloom
mind Bloom is the leader in at home
ketamine therapy offering a combination
of scientifically robust medicine with
clinically guided support for people
looking to improve their mental health
and well-being
if you or someone you love is struggling
with mental health issues they probably
Loom large in your life there is no
one-size-fits-all solution but you know
that you or your loved one need
something that will
there is no one-size-fits-all solution
but you know that you or your loved one
needs something that will help achieve a
real and Lasting breakthrough maybe it's
time you check out a guided ketamine
Therapy Program from mind Bloom mind
Bloom could be your next and most
successful chapter in mental health and
well-being Improvement mind Bloom
connects patients to licensed
psychiatric clinicians to help them
achieve better outcomes with lower costs
greater convenience and an artfully
crafted experience
to begin take mind blooms on online
assessment and schedule a video consult
with a licensed uh
with a licensed clinician to determine
if mind Bloom is right for you if
approved you will discuss your health
history and goals for mental health
treatment with your clinician to tailor
your mind Bloom regimen mind Bloom will
send you a kit in the mail complete with
medicine treatment materials and tips
for getting the most out of your
experience after only four sessions 89
percent of Mind Bloom clients reported
improvements in their symptoms of
depression and anxiety
reports uh one client on their site I
thought I was broken now the light
inside me is growing stronger every day
let mind Bloom guide you into a better
chapter of mental health and well-being
right now mind Bloom is offering our
listeners 100 off your first six session
program when you sign up at
mindbloom.com Darkhorse and use the
promo code darkhorset checkout go to
mindbloom.com
Darkhorse promo code Darkhorse for a
hundred dollars off your first
succession program today that's mind
Bloom m i n d b l o m.com slash
darkhorsepromocode Darkhorse
foreign
well we have a number of things to talk
about today
shall I start or would you like to start
why don't you start
um
I wanted us to talk a little bit about
the experience of and the threat of
cancellation
okay
this is you know this is a concept that
is mocked by many uh in in various
venues and of particular political
events largely but you know we pretty
famously got canceled in 2017 and
you know much to the irritation of our
enemies emerged in in different form
phoenix-like from the canceled into the
realm of the uh here we are now yes
right here we are now here we are now
and you know it took some it took some
doing and it took some time and it uh
and and there's no guarantees but of
course uh part of what happened to us
was we actually had tenure which is to
say we had the guarantees and then those
guarantees proved not to be any
guarantees at all and uh when a mob came
at you uh Brett and then me
uh with irrationality and spurious
claims and uh and frankly violence and
nonsense and everything in between uh
instead of standing up uh most of our
colleagues and uh basically the entire
College administration
uh coward in fear we had a certain
amount of support in private but not
very much in public I was on sabbatical
at the time so I didn't have any active
students but your students stood by you
and us and to a person that to a person
and that is one of the pieces of that
story that has largely been missed the
idea like ah aren't students crazy and
weren't wasn't that terrible and you
know isn't isn't student culture and
isn't that generation just insane well
like no
no that's not the case because as it
turns out if you're actually an
excellent Professor who really cares
about your students
you you develop relationships with them
such that when Liars come at you and say
you're this they can say no actually I
know this man and you're not right
so yeah I do want to add something I
think
the reality is even more Stark great the
fact it's even worse than that and it's
even more it's even better than that in
this case
um
not only did none of my students defect
which I think is what the protesters
were absolutely expecting is that you
know you protest a white Professor on
the basis that he's a racist and it
doesn't much matter what the reality is
you would expect students to join that
protest because it's an of the moment
thing and not a one did well it's it's
uh it's inherent to today's logic look
at your skin therefore you are racist
right right we we must cure you and
you're incurable that's how we know you
are one right that's the kind of logic
right but not only did none of my
students defect but several of them
including a number of students of color
courageously stood up and defended me
and were punished specifically for it
because that was a bad look for the
protesters
um there were attempts at re-education
yep there were attempts at re-education
but also the long history of students
that we'd had we did none of those
people showed up and made crazy claims
about racism either right it didn't
happen and the final piece of that
puzzle is that all of the students who
did show up
you know 50 or so students who poured
through the door and made these
accusations
never met a single one of them right so
the point is it's like absolutely clean
that those with experience weren't
persuaded by this story you had to have
exactly zero direct experience in order
to be involved in that in the first
place but of course none of that you
know
I we are lucky
that all of those facts emerged right
that these protesters were foolish
enough to film what they did so that it
showed up in public so that we could
have that discussion so it didn't just
look like oh you know
that Professor is clearly off and the
students have risen up against them and
all of that the the LIE got put to their
claim but for most people presumably
that is not what happens right it
doesn't become a famous incident and so
well and in the particular the
particular kind of professoring that you
did and that I did in the particular
model that only Evergreen afforded meant
that you really had
um deep relationships with your students
where most college professors don't in
part because they have no interest in it
uh which is unfortunately true for many
but also the standard model of higher ed
standard model of almost all education
now with some interesting exceptions
over in
um you know Waldorf and Montessori space
um and a few other experiments in higher
ed but nothing like Evergreen the the
standard model is you know I'll see you
for 50 minutes three times a week or
maybe an hour and a half two times a
week or something and if it's a lab
class then you know you'll have
three hours at a time but it's probably
with a TA probably never gonna see the
professor maybe he or she'll walk
through once right and that you can
learn some things that way
what you cannot do is develop Community
as a as a class it is therefore more
difficult more time consuming less
predictable you can't just
um set it and go set it and forget it as
the professor nor can you as the student
and and so it is you know it's it's more
challenging in almost every regard but
it is it has the potential to be so much
more educational and one of the proofs
of that is that when a mob showed up on
your doorstep those people who were in
your classroom which at another school
with another professor might have been
eager to jump in with the mob and have
that kind of fun because a lot of people
like to be in mobs or at least they want
to be on the side of the majority
no one bit yeah right and that is in
part a result of actually the
educational model well and it's even
better than that because in the case of
these students we had had extensive
conversations about human evolution
about population versus population
competition we had talked about race we
had talked about why racism appears and
what we have to do in order to negate
its uh its influence so
it wasn't like anybody had to think
about whether or not a claim of racism
might mean something because the point
is we'd had those discussions and to the
extent that there was a Charged
discussion it had been diffused because
we'd been through it and if there had
been any hint of racism they would have
detected it and they didn't and so it
was like a very quick check out that
doesn't add up yeah so anyway it isn't
an argument and a strong one for a very
intensive model of Education I would
point out Jacob the uh Beaver researcher
and conservationist uh is a very good
demonstration of what sort of amazing
people were in those classrooms
absolutely um so anyway yeah it is a
model that someone should resurrect
because it's yes we have made some
attempts haven't we yeah so far
unsuccessfully but uh maybe maybe again
and we also get asked by people okay
well where can I send my my kids it's
like well
um as I have said as I have written
about with regard to the University of
Boston for instance like yes the woke
needs to go but it's not sufficient you
know you need you need a different
educational model which yes will be more
challenging for the faculty and will
take more of their time and attention
away from if they don't really want to
be teaching if they don't really want to
be in the classroom or the field at the
lab or whatever with students if that's
just a distraction that they feel like
that's Penance they have to pay before
they can get back to their main work
which is their research over here then
they're not going to be interested in a
full-time model of of Education like
Evergreen had and they're not going to
be good at if they're forced to it yeah
the uh the the hidden aspect of that is
full time is a description of one
parameter the freedom to make use of
that full-time interaction is both the
beauty of it and the Achilles heel
because you have to be inclined not over
not only to have that kind of intensive
teaching relationship but to figure out
what to do with it and uh I think I said
on the podcast with Jacob that the thing
you know Evergreen gave you total
freedom to figure out what to do but it
never figured out what to do with
professors who couldn't figure it out
and that if it had figured out how to
keep only those professors who after
three years had demonstrated a
willingness and a desire to innovate new
things with all of that freedom then it
would have been a great place because it
would have been filled with people who
made use of that to the benefit of their
students and that the tragedy of what
happened at Evergreen is in large
measure because
um that was it was hit and miss with
respect to whether an individual faculty
was up to the task or not yep too often
miss unfortunately
so all of that is sort of lead up to
2017 was rough that was that you know
May 23 2017 is when the mob showed up at
your door that whole academic year 2016
to 2017 and even before that but
especially that year it was it was
roiling and it blew up and it was
September before we knew for sure that
we were not going to be professors
anymore and it was you know it was a
full-on reversal of you know our entire
lives reversal is the wrong word an
upending we went through the Looking
Glass in in the language that we started
to use and one of the things that you
see after you go through the Looking
Glass is oh
survived it's actually interesting over
here there's some interesting people
that I couldn't see before and also when
people make false claims at you when
they yell at you that you're a bigot
um and you're not because you checked
with yourself and you're self-aware
enough and honest enough with yourself
to know and you have friends and family
around you who will tell you if you're
wrong you can say yep nope not true
right and and it is also extraordinarily
obvious that most of the time it's the
people claiming bigot who are infected
bigots right and that and that we know
most of our audience will already be
well familiar with with this but one of
you know now we are we will be six years
out uh this this year
um yeah we have we we have now of course
covet has happened and we've had a
different kind of run-in with sort of
cancellation this you know the
demonetization the shadow Banning that
you know and the actual Banning of some
things like the unity account but the
demonetization by YouTube all of these
things are kinds of cancellation but the
like cancellation by mob using
um woke language to cow everyone into
silence and compliance
I figured we were completely free of and
I unfortunately in the last few weeks
came to see the naivete of that position
because what is true is that if you have
connections if if there are other people
whom you love in the world who are not
free in the same way who have not been
pre-canceled as we have been and are
thus immune to that particular thing
then the mob can come for them because
of their association with you
and this this was attempted and I'm just
I'm going to speak in kind of vague
terms here we may speak more more in
more detailed and precise ways later but
but for now for today we're gonna we're
gonna keep it vague
but I will say that
um I found myself in the face of a dear
friend of mine being at risk of losing
and I'm going to use that crazy
um
plural pronoun just to obscure this
person's sex at risk of losing their
their job
because they insisted that no they are
actually friends with me and I'm an
evolutionary biologist and I believe
that they're two Sexes and only two
Sexes and humans and that you can't
switch between them
it is my purported transphobia which a
is does not mean what it they claim it
means and B if it means anything at all
it means all sorts of things because
what trans is is all sorts of things
right and as we have said over and over
and over again as I have written over
and over and over again
um I know trans people I understand
trans to actually be a condition a a
condition of Being Human for very very
very rare people who actually feel
deeply inside of themselves that in
order to live their lives as they need
to live them they need to live them as
the sex that they are not
such people are generally not confused
about having actually transitioned sex
and all the rest of it which is the vast
majority of what is passing for Trans
and trans rights activism and trans
activism in general now is either
um misogynistic and regressive to you
know gender Norms of the 50s if you like
wearing a dress you must be a woman hmm
no wrong
but there are you know I can I could
Riff on all the ways that trans is and
is not represented accurately in in
modern activism now but the short
version here is that
someone tried to take my friend out
because he is friends with an
evolutionary biologist who knows and I
use the word believe before but who
knows that in the human lineage there
are two and only two Sexes and there
have been for at least 500 million years
and maybe up to two billion years
and furthermore and I wrote about this a
little bit in my Natural Selections
piece this last week
um in mammals there are no known cases
of functional hermaphrodites or being
able to switch between Sexes and mammals
is a really old clade far older than
when than chick celebs 65 million years
ago at the Cretaceous tertiary boundary
when you know a giant piece of rock hit
the Earth around the Yucatan and wiped
out the non-avian dinosaurs and then you
had the rise of the mammals but mammals
existed before then we've got you know
mammals are very very old and we don't
have any evidence anywhere in mammal
history ever of mammals being able to
actually switch sex
genders the software
gender is the Manifest the behavioral
manifestation and can you have you know
men who behave more like typically
typical women and vice versa yeah you
can and that doesn't change what they
are fundamentally so that all is
over in some specific territory
the thing that
really grabbed me okay there are a
couple things to say one
yeah mammals did exist before uh the uh
the extinction of the non-avian
dinosaurs but they were oppressed by
them they were it was the age of
dinosaurs I mean you've seen how we've
named it now even even mammals named it
the age of dinosaurs right it was the
age of dinosaurs and now we are in the
age of mammals because there are only
two and a third times as many dinosaur
species still on the earth as there are
mammals but never mind that we are the
ones who do the naming and so yeah now
ostriches don't get to name things so no
they do not no it's not gonna happen
anytime soon ostriches yeah the other
thing I want to say is
this is actually exactly parallel to my
students having known better than to
accept the claim that I that there was
some history of racism the moment those
people streamed through the door my
students knew it was Bull right
I hear you accused of transphobia right
yeah I have seen you I have seen you
take care of trans students I have seen
you fret over the difficulties they run
into in the world and
um the very idea that your
um you know what we have is a movement
that is actually parasitizing transness
right this rare but real phenomenon it
is parasitizing that in order to gain
access to a protected status that then
allows it to do things like uh you know
when swimming competitions and things
like this or there's you know to use
biological framing there's a mimicry so
a parasitizing yes for sure but it also
it's pretending to be the same thing
yeah right and in a non-human setting at
the point that the mimic so vastly
outnumbers outnumbers the model which is
to say the true original thing yeah
the whole system falls apart right like
everyone else who's sort of on the
outside observing mimics and models as
it were uh can can see that it doesn't
make any sense and it doesn't work the
signal doesn't work anymore right and
there are a few there are some of us out
here saying that's not like no wrong but
unfortunately the good half-ish of the
country who's thinking about this at all
is compelled by these talking points and
all they have to do is go transphobe and
the the obvious discrepancies and and
damage being done especially to children
by this ideology just disappears because
people are scared of being called themes
and you were remarkably
not scared of being called racist
because you had already investigated
very carefully and thought and knew no
not true I similarly am not scared of
being called a transphobe because a the
word isn't meaningful in the same way
that racist you at least used to be
meaningful but to the degree that it
means in the very narrow sense no not
true
however
I did find myself
wavering in this situation in a way I
never did because because they took a
hostage because
because but look this is the this is a
really important point
when they came at you and then very
quickly they came at us but it was even
if even if I had somehow remained
invisible to the Mob that came for you
um there was it we were in it together
we've been in it together from the
beginning
um you know I
I vetted and edited and okayed
everything you said out to those crazy
people in advance fighting against the
ideology right like we were in it
together whether or not they knew that
yep
I assume and hope that you never doubted
that that I would say can we just
could we could we just give in can we
just right that was never never entered
my mind never an option for me and I
assumed that you knew that and and you
did
but it's not my right
to expect someone else whom I love but
isn't my life partner
to stand strong
when when they could say yeah you know
what I do disagree with her yeah maybe
not my friend right it would have been
easy for this person and in fact
because
because they are who they are it wasn't
going to happen and they didn't want me
to do that and they wanted us to be
working together to figure out what to
do with me knowing for sure that that
wasn't going to happen but it was harder
for me to have the certainty because I
felt like something about me has dragged
you into this the mob took a hostage
this makes it so much more challenging
actually
all right two points one I want to make
sure to come back to this because this
puts the shoe on exactly the other foot
for me on an issue where I have been
I've been clear and I'm probably in
error so I'd like to come back to that
um but I want to talk about the
confidence when the mob shows up right
where does the confidence that the
accusation has no merit and therefore
does not require you know
hand ringing or you know extensive
contemplation that comes from somewhere
yeah and I think it can only be one
place
which is that you have already done the
contemplation
if you're trying to think this through
as the mob is accusing you of things
yeah right you're not gonna they can
confuse you they can sway you perhaps
and you know your your instincts is a
good person like well wait a second it's
not my right to shut somebody down who
thinks I've got a moral defect it's my
obligation to to investigate that I need
to listen to criticism thing will be
weaponized against you and so the point
is look when those students were
accusing me of racism
there is a reason that I had exactly no
concern about this and it's because this
has never been a Charged issue it wasn't
a Charged issue in my family we talked
openly about it we dealt with the
difficulties and so to whatever extent I
might have a misunderstanding and I'm
sure that I do it wasn't the result of a
moral defect it wasn't the result of me
rooting for one group against another
and in fact I was very clear on you know
what I did think about this issue right
what I thought the unfortunate features
of the system were what I thought the
places that Humanity was lucky because
where race could be a worse issue
um the the biology that underlies this
is much less horrible than it might be
um but in any case it is the
the navigation in advance
right that is why you also have no fear
on the issue of transphobia right
because you've done this work in advance
over the course of years with different
real-life people it's not a theoretical
question for you
this is the problem though what the mob
is doing one of the many things the mob
is doing is it is making it impossible
to have a discussion in which you figure
out what you think and why right it is
making it impossible for us to present
evidence you know it comes up with
arbitrary rules like you're not a one of
those so you're not allowed to talk
about those all right if that's a rule
then the point is well how will I learn
how it's not my job to teach you well
how about I learn on my own no you're
not allowed to think about those things
because you're not one of those right
and you know you can't make a joke about
this
okay I can't make a joke about this
because it will make people feel unsafe
and not being safe is bad and you know
so okay now there's a rule against
making a joke well but the problem is
jokes even jokes that go too far right
of which there are many many jokes even
jokes that go too far help us figure out
where too far is and why it's there
right what makes a joke funny involves
figuring out where that line is Right
without humor the line still exists but
no one can point to it right and the
fact is you know uh there are trans
people I gotta say it's an odd
phenomenon right it's an interesting
phenomenon it would be shocking if there
was nothing funny about it right it
would be it would be utterly shocking
right we can say the same thing about
homosexuality frankly we can say the
same thing about races and the various
arbitrary differences between us right
these are all grounds for humor and
humorous and the differences between men
and women of course right all of these
things and so the point is it's no
accident that the point is you're not
one of those you can't talk about it and
you sure as hell can't make a joke right
because if you you know if you could
make jokes then you could figure out
where you stood and why and then you'd
be immune when they came through the
door and so it's all kind of a matter of
frustrating any normal process that
would protect you so that you're
vulnerable and then can be manipulated
to be absorbed into the mob and to go
after the next person which is why this
thing is contagious and dangerous is
that it picks people up well it picks
people up whom it has already made as
ignorant and confused as possible
so that they are least likely to be able
to defend themselves against techniques
that are authoritarian and
um
mean and frankly bigoted and and they
part of what they do is they take all of
their characters which include being
authoritarian and mean spirited and
bigoted and they accuse you of being
those things and of course whenever you
deny a thing it it forever after there
is an association with people who maybe
don't know you very well it's like oh
wasn't she the one who denied the thing
right and but
yeah there there is a lot of bigotry in
society still and
some of the traditional kinds of bigotry
do exist
it was waning fast yeah that was waning
fast and what we have now is on you know
on the side of the political spectrum
that we used to be unabashedly on
without any suggestion that we might
maybe not really belong on the left like
that's at least how I felt right for my
entire life
it is that side now that is embracing
bigotry
that is embracing
name calling and cancellation
and threats and authoritarianism and
it's doing so in the Name of Love
and it's a lie
some of them are confused themselves and
some of them know that they're full of
it
but it's wrong regardless of how they
get there
and you know enough with the fake you
know love above all stuff from the
people who are acting in exactly the
opposite way
like there are a lot of very loving
people out there who don't look like
what these mobs want them to look like
and frankly the feelings of the people
and the mobs
cannot continue to describe for us what
it is that we're allowed to do and say
in the world
so
a couple things before we get to the the
second point where the shoe is now on
the other foot for me oh yeah
one I was doing a little thinking you
know I I think you were doing a lot of
thinking yeah I was I have been doing a
lot of thinking recently and before yeah
yeah
um but okay so you and I agree
bigotry was waning fast and was not all
that common right now the problem is you
can hear as you say that into a
microphone you can hear the Pearl
clutching and the fainting couch
reaching and the Hand ringing and the
consternation and the calls to have
meetings to discuss the you know problem
of people who are so dumb they don't see
how much bigotry there is everywhere I
think we could solve these problems with
more meetings oh definitely meetings
yeah an email is not going to cover it
no no in-person meetings oh no maybe
Zoom meetings Zoom meeting sitting in
the same room right but still done by
Zoom right because then you can turn off
your camera if you're snickering and how
foolish the other people are being and
listening to your um sorry I
I am I I delayed you I distracted you
you derailed that's the d word I was
looking for yesterday yeah which is a
kind of violence
derailing I'm not sorry
um
weird okay no remorse red flag
um you know what it is
no apologies for things I didn't do
really I know is that your rule yeah
that seems somehow morally compromised
in some way I'll have to pencil out
later yeah but there I was derailing you
again for which I will apologize
rederailed me yeah yes
um D Squared
derailed me I don't know but yeah so far
the math derailments are not going well
this is not a good math morning but uh
yeah but the gist the gist is right so
um in any case the uh here's what I've
been realizing okay and you know you
spelled it out okay bigotry was
rapidly disappearing from the landscape
um to the point that when Jeremy Lee
Quinn and I were talking on our program
remind our audience
freelance journalist who has been in all
of the hot spots including January 60 so
Lefty uh Anarchist but anyway a very
good journalist
was there on January 6th actually went
into the Capitol and observed it
firsthand anyway interesting guy and he
was describing I think he was actually
describing January 6 to me when I
interviewed him and and uh he told me
with some excitement that he had
actually met a racist like a guy was
just admitting it and talking about yeah
he didn't dig other races and all of
this and I was excited too because
neither of us had ever met one of these
people in the wild right they're very
rare like and was he in a cage or did he
get to touch him right it was remarkable
that he even had a sign you could just
find him in the crowd based on his sign
I'm a racist pretty much something to
that effect yeah and so you know there
is something a little bit I don't know
quaint about that that it's somebody who
is so off the living dodo bird right
he's a he's a living dodo
um but anyway so they are rare but then
you can hear the Pearl clutching and
fainting couch reaching and all of the
stuff that people do because of course
they know from personal experience just
how much of this stuff is out there no
you don't what what is out there still
in large quantities is ignorance
absolutely which is not the same thing
as bigotry yep right so anyway we've
been making that distinction for a long
time there's lots of ignorance you and I
have plenty of ignorance too as does
everybody else but I'm not saying that
I'm there's nothing to the accusation
that I'm a racist but yeah I've got
ignorance and you know I didn't grow up
in anybody else's home I didn't grow up
in anyone else's culture it's simply
that but then you make the next point
which is actually though racism is
common it's just back that's what it is
it's a new kind it's some sort of Neo
bigotry
right and uh I think that's the sticking
point is that now the racists look very
different from what they once did you
know it's not that retro dude at the
January 6th protest uh it's some kind of
new racism where the focuses are
different but nonetheless it's
um you know this obsession with race
right which D individuates people and
exposes people to you know again it's
you know it doesn't matter that you
think you're doing it because you want
to be good the point is no you're
separating us by race again and you're
taking away the thing that's key to
Being Human and substituting something
you know grotesque that does you know
superficial superficial official and
there's no way it could possibly work
hmm
so actually I did have a uh a thought
about how to deal again I imagine I had
a few but I thought this one was good
we'll see
um so the idea is how do you deal with
these new racists right and so what I
was thinking is um
you
you just carry around with you for the
moment that you need it um some Saltines
in a little package and then when you
encounter uh one of these white folks
that is now newly obsessed with race you
just uh cracker
my feeling is that that would be it's at
least a conversation starter you at
least might get a few gaskets blown they
might blow a gasket right exactly no
they could start I don't know where we
have our gaskets actually
human gaskets yeah oh uh the blood brain
barrier I think that oh that's that's
probably it that's the one that's
probably it so so
covered by the custom gasket blowing a
little a little gasket blowing yeah yeah
and some haphazard repairs all right so
you were you also wanted to go somewhere
else uh the shoe on the other foot thing
yeah so
for
since we ended up in the public eye as a
result of the unfortunate thing that
happened at Evergreen to me and then to
us
people have come to me regularly and
they have basically said I'm in a
terrible situation it's happening to me
what should I do
and it is clear that when somebody comes
to me they pretty much want to hear me
say okay here's how you stand up to that
and I'm very reluctant to do this right
especially if it's not someone you know
right and you don't know anything about
all of their circumstances
right because what I know is that you
and I landed on our feet and we landed
on our feet for lots of different
reasons we had
a good support network we did lose a
bunch of friends but there was enough
there to escape the implosion of
Evergreen and to make our way in the
world in a different in a different
manner
I don't know that for anybody else right
and if somebody stands up to the Mob
because it's the right thing to do and
they lose their job and their family is
imperiled or worse because of that
catastrophe then I don't want to be the
one to say yeah it's cool to stand up to
the Mob because as much as I think it's
important that we stand up to mobs it's
not all you know look
if we hadn't landed on our feet
we at least have family
right we have family and
it would have protected our children
not everybody's in that spot right so
anyway I've been very reluctant to give
the advice that I know people want me to
give and other heterodox folks have
often confronted me over this like why
won't you tell them what they want to
hear we need people to stand up that's
how we're going to defeat if they're
coming to you you know what they want to
hear right and I agree we do need them
to stand up but I still it's my moral
responsibility not to give somebody
advice that would be good for me but
potentially bad for them in their
situation right so anyway I have
failed to deliver the advice that I know
is probably for the global best because
it is interpersonally not fair to expose
somebody to them
this is the situation that you have
found yourself in here where somebody
that you care very much about was taken
as a hostage by a mob that had some
power to do harm and I see you going
through exactly the
um the various machinations over
um you know the responsibility of oh my
God I put this person in in Peril right
and it I will feel terrible if this by
knowing that there are two Sexes animals
right by doing your job right right
um but yes no and I and I and I said to
them at some point sort of in the middle
of this like I
I don't think this is what
you're thinking of doing I don't think
you want to do it I don't think this is
what you want to hear from me
this is mostly about me relieving
pressure on myself
you know you I need you to know
that it's okay if you know if you
disavow me like if yeah and I
you know they didn't of course they
wouldn't normally they wouldn't yeah
they wouldn't it was never a possibility
but I just felt such
it's not it's no longer just about me
and like this this is so fundamentally
The Human Condition yeah right and I
didn't I didn't see this coming exactly
because
we went through this together and so I
felt I had I knew and you know we had
students and there was like there were
effects on students and like we were
navigating all of that in real time
I just I I didn't see this coming where
I felt both responsible to while knowing
that I was in no way responsible for
yeah the situation right responsible to
the person
making sure that they wouldn't feel
that they didn't feel obligated to a
sense to me to do something that was
going to imperil
lots of things
um while also knowing as did they as
this everyone who can see this with any
Clarity like I'm not responsible for
this thing this is about the bigoted mob
on the other side
wielding power
yep
um with some
wiggle room over individual cases where
somebody truly has extreme Jeopardy yeah
I'm now seeing the situation differently
because I'm watching you make the
arguments that I would make and I'm
watching you feel the responsibility
that I would feel and I feel very
differently from the outside
um and I think the key thing is a we
know how this Dynamic works it's not
like the first time anybody's seen this
kind of mob we've seen this mob hundreds
of times right in many different
contexts it's always the same right you
apologize to it does it get placated no
quite the opposite give them an inch
right they take it off second thing is
it is a
contagious game theoretic object right
its purpose is to get you to back down
so that it will move on to the next
person and the point is by backing down
you fuel it so in one sense you know
you've got a person who is confronted
with an unfortunate mob right that
person is in Peril and the instinct is
oh my goodness to the extent that I'm
responsible for you being confronted by
a mob I feel absolutely obligated to do
everything I can to get you out from in
front of that mob however
if you do that
the mob comes for somebody else right
and so and destroys all the good things
right along the way and so in some sense
we're dealing you know it's it's 2023
right this happened to us in 2017. we
did stand strong and we demonstrated how
that could be done and we were lucky to
be in a position where we were
comparatively uh well situated to do it
but
we needed more people to do it in order
that it wouldn't still be going on in
2023 yeah and so in some sense I'm now
looking back at the people who I was
reluctant to say no actually you really
do have to stand up people who as you
point out came to me because that's what
they wanted to hear and given that they
came to me and that's what they wanted
to hear I probably should have said it
oh interesting
that's what I think okay
good
um
okay
new topic new topic new topic I think
yeah yeah
um there's so many different things to
talk about here uh do you want to go or
do you want me to pick another pick
another topic for my little list I know
you've got two big things that you want
to talk about yeah and I've got I I can
I can segue here if you like or why
don't you you continue on we'll pick up
the other two afterwards okay
um
I was for my
Natural Selections piece this week which
was broadly on
um
hold on um I'm just gonna make sure this
works yes uh don't show my screen yet
Zach what I'm about to ask you to
um
my Natural Selections this week was
broadly on sort of dominance hierarchies
I had I had tweeted something a month
ago a month and a half ago responding to
sort of a naive understanding of what an
alpha male is and then we also got a
quest asked a question about it in our q
a last week and I was thinking about you
know how humans don't really have alpha
males and a lot of people think alpha
male is a is is not a thing at all and
that's not exactly true but it is kind
of an archaic term it's not really
what's used much in animal behavior
anymore but uh there are a lot of
reasons to expect that humans don't
behave like say gorillas
but also we have
well you can read the piece this is this
I did not mean to embark on a question
of what an alpha male is but everyone
will have something that comes up in
their mind when they think alpha male so
I wrote this piece
and I needed a picture to go out with
social media when it went out and so I
looked on Getty get images and you may
now show my screen Zach uh we've just
put Getty Images across all of these so
there's no copyright risk I'm just gonna
I just screenshot at the top images uh
when I do alpha male and I will describe
them for those of you just listening
we've got a a virus being injected with
a with a needle
we've got a guy and a like a plague mask
from the middle from the Middle Ages
I've got a close-up of a researcher and
a like a hazmat suit and a mask and some
kind of a vial
hands dude in a mask with a syringe a
hand with a syringe a biohazard bag
um a guy sitting alone in bamboo
a
I don't even know what how do I describe
that a dorky looking guy flexing his
muscles yeah looking angry because that
and that was the point of this thing
like that I wrote It's like actually
it's not about anger and violence it's
about conciliation anyway
um
on and on and on I'm not going to
describe all of them but almost all of
these are like blue suited white suited
uh you know masked people with syringes
or phones or syringes on all masks and
this like this is this is what Getty
gives up when you say I'm looking for
pictures of an alpha male finally at the
at the very end of what I'm going to
show you here then we have just like
three pictures of randomly happy people
most of whom aren't men masked most of
whom aren't men at all and then a
kangaroo which like as far as I could
tell it's the first possible alpha male
I've seen here right this kangaroo yes I
mean in fact the uh and maybe it's I
don't even know I can't sex a kangaroo
at this distance maybe that's even a
female I don't know
um
it's not worth delving too deeply here
but it's possible that in that cluster
of four images
three of those images appear to be of
the same scene where the dude is
standing like he's a college student
standing next to two female college
students no it is yeah one of them has
changed a shirt and one of them but no
it is you're right yeah so anyway it's
possible that that's what they're
getting at but there is something very
odd here now when you showed me this I
thought
something is wrong where's this and I'm
just like it may be just even
algorithmically broken and I wondered if
you know it wasn't bringing up all of
these coveted images which would be more
at home in a search if you searched
pandemic or covid you would expect those
images yeah um but so I did a test and I
searched for Alpha
um just to see if it was talking about a
variant if that's why it was triggered
nope didn't happen so anyway it is the
alpha male search and mail doesn't do it
either right yeah so there's something
about those combination of terms that is
triggering you know maybe it's just
algorithmic
um
but uh anyway it's
there's a question about what's going on
here
there's very much a question about
what's going on here uh does our
producer want to say something yeah
that's not our experience at all when we
checked it was not the same images but
it was also lots of code images
unfortunately so Zach and I are having a
disagreement do you want me to I don't
know do you want me to talk to Mike you
could talk into the mic
um we can't show you the images because
of the way Getty Works
um and we would be putting ourselves in
Jeopardy if we showed those images
without
um without putting Gary across so just
to clarify what I just said my sense
when we searched up Alpha was not the
same images but related images now that
is that is correct what we saw for Alpha
variant at least no no no it was just
Alpha I just plugged in Alpha uh so we
saw a lot of images that were like
pictures of a virus but not pictures of
people with syringes it was definitely
odd the alpha male search was
particularly weird and I also searched
interestingly if you plug in beta mail
it's identical the search is like
identical to alpha male which is weird
yeah so I you know I don't know and I've
got one more set of images to show as
well you know again I was just looking
for an image for for this piece and I
tried gender Norms now before we show
this one don't show my screen just yet
Zach I will say that I did this search
back it would have been Monday night and
when you guys redid this search just now
this morning it came it came up with
totally different answers so you know
again again and again and again I I have
to wonder and we should all be wondering
to what degree am I seeing what other
people see to what degree is a search a
search right and I you know I thought
you know we we have purchased access to
Gettys to to use professionally and I
would have thought that a search would
be a search yep uh and you know you
would you would expect it to change over
time as new pictures get added as the
cultural Maloo changes whatever milieu
but alpha male and gender Norm
which is the other search that I did
here would seem to have nothing to do
with covid
and so if you search on alpha male and
what you get is a whole bunch of
pictures of covety syringe things it's
very very very odd and then what we see
if you want to show my screen now Zach
when I searched on gender dorm and again
this was not replicated today five days
later
is
what appears to be pictures from
China maybe of people being given
um throat swabs
just
over and over and over and over again
for it's amazing the search on gender
norm and then then we end up at baseball
so I'm just baffled yeah and and and
continue to be you know concerned in
places like the evidence for concern
shows up in places I was not expecting
it at all right so uh as you will recall
years ago
um when we were professors and creating
lectures
the typical thing you did yours
differently than I did but in general
there was a sort of sense that we would
build a lecture in PowerPoint and then
deliver it in one way or another in
front of the class and I became
pretty adamant this is long before
anybody had confronted us over anything
but I didn't like the idea
that when I gave a lecture and I was
going to talk about the evolution of
Love or something right that if you plug
uh if you search for a random image
which you tend to find are images of
well-heeled white people in the Western
World in Love on a beach or whatever
right and I so I used to have to trick
the search engine into giving me images
you know why if you plug love into a
search engine why are you not likely to
come up with hunter-gatherers in some
place on Earth fewer pictures for one
thing and it's less often what people
think they're looking for but of course
that reinforces what they think they're
looking for right but okay at the very
least there should be a wide range of
images from different cultures since
every culture has this feature right it
should be it should not be heavily
biased in some direction and so I used
to have to counteract the heavy bias
inside of Google and
um at one point I was talking to my
students about the fact that I was doing
this and they clued me into the fact
that actually Google was sensitive to
where you were searching from and that
if you tricked it into where you it
thought you were you got a different
bias
um so anyway there's some long-standing
thing and there's a genuine problem how
do you solve the problem of um
delivering images that are
representative rather than reflective of
a bias in the population that's likely
to be searching or the expectations or
desires of those research and why not
you want a search engine to give you an
actual reflection of the world rather
than to reinforce biases but as soon as
you start trying to correct for uh
biases then the point is you're in
danger of introducing biases and anyway
it's a difficult problem Zach has
something to add I just need to correct
something that I told you that was
incorrect which dad and I tried to find
out when I just saw what you showed um
it turns out that when I tried to
replicate your search for gender Norm I
was using the wrong category you know
what I mean mom uh but anyway I just
replicated it's identical so that's
actually okay
replicate now so they're they're
identical if I some now compared to when
you switched them a few days ago so
that's not a data point there just
interesting yeah yeah so I don't
honestly know what it means I don't you
know I I don't see how I don't see how
this functions to anyone's benefit
honestly
um
with regard to gender norms and thread
swabs it makes I can't get anywhere with
it with regard to
um alpha males and people being masked
and and getting
syringes poked at them I can see how
this is consistent with a narrative that
we are we are being asked to agree to
which is that you're so if you're not
you're not doing your duty and you're
not you know maybe you're not being a
good man if you don't do the thing that
the government is asking you to do well
I have a hypothesis that is
um
simultaneously worse and maybe less
targeted
so I know from what little I've done
Yeti image searches that there are
places where it just doesn't have
anything right because it's actually
buying access to these photos it doesn't
you know things that get particularly
right but someone at getty tags them so
you know I can see taking a lot of
pictures like the picture I should show
the picture that I ended up using uh
which was from a search on alpha male
and I'm gonna just keep talking so I can
find it here
um excuse me
was presumably my guess is that uh
this person who took this picture you
can show it now Zach
um did not take it and think Ah that's a
picture of an alpha male right but it
got tagged this way and I looked at it
and went goldfinches at a feeder yep
there's like the the one guy that's
looking at the bird coming in that's a
territorial interaction at least yeah
right so I I know I interrupted you but
I don't yes there are certainly Arenas
where there aren't very many pictures
but someone someone within each of you
know flicker within each of these places
that is Distributing pictures is
deciding how to tag photos right but uh
remember my claim was that my hypothesis
would be both better and worse okay so
the idea is you have a repository that
isn't a
collect everything and you know let some
AI tag it it's more deliberate and more
selective than that it's good images
they you know are manually tagged and so
it's a much smaller pool which means
that if you search things that nobody
ever searches the search doesn't have
anything for you right Getty doesn't
know that it should be looking for
pictures of gender Norms right maybe
that's not a very common search as a
matter of fact it probably isn't a very
common search
um likewise alpha male you know maybe
but so imagine the following imagine
that there is a nudge in the search that
biases every search a little bit so it
just puts in a smattering of this um
here's what people are
doing you know they're getting jabbed
they're taking swabs they're doing this
stuff and that when the algorithm comes
up empty because you've thrown it a
challenge it's not good at
the only thing there is the nudge
and so the point is it spits out a bunch
of stuff that has nothing to do with
your search it has to do with the fact
that there's a very subtle Notch built
in to the algorithm and in the absence
of any other data that nudge becomes uh
much larger than life right and it's a
testable hypothesis of course because it
once you know that there's going to be
empty categories we could go search some
things that we expect to be pretty empty
and see whether we get the nudge right
in the direction of everything yeah oh
that's good I mean it's terrible but
it's see I told you both better and
worse yeah indeed
um so I'm going to save one of the
things I was going to talk about for
next week and I got one little tiny
thing to maybe add at the end or I can
add it here or uh let's uh you'll add it
at the end okay um so
the first thing that I wanted to talk
about of my two topics here is on my
mind because of an essay that was just
published by a good friend of ours Holly
math nerd is her uh her gnome de plume
it's here on my screen if you want to
show it yeah you wanna
put it up
um it's called next step in the war on
kids next step in the war on kids and
I'm not telling any Tales out of school
to say that Holly is somebody who had an
absolutely
horrifying childhood and she has written
about it written about the the abuse
that she faced and
um her
struggles in dealing with it and
basically you know she's an amazingly
capable person who has
um you know she's in some ways
self-constructed in a way that most of
us just simply aren't right because she
had to you know break the programs that
she got from her traumatic childhood and
replaced them with better stuff which is
a
a difficult process
in any case she has been
um very
uh
sensitive to and I think prescient about
a March towards the normalization of
pedophilia that is clearly occurring
anyway her new essay is about a
next step in that March towards the
normalizing of pedophilia in society
which I had never even heard of until
she alerted me to it
um and what it has to do with is
a new term now many people will be at
some level familiar with a term that
recently emerged which is
a minor attracted persons which is
basically a an antiseptic sounding
legitimizing term that substitutes for
pedophile right so if you were going to
normalize this pedophile of course sets
people on edge as it should and the idea
is you know in a world where people are
you know obsessed with the idea that you
know you shouldn't shame anybody for any
Kink they might have and the idea is
this sort of swaps this terrible thing
in under the radar by describing it like
any other
um sexual proclivity right so that's bad
enough and we've many of us have seen
this trend and understood the hazard in
it but then there's sort of a next phase
the new phase involves another term
again I've never heard it before which I
think is adult attracted minor
and
um this one
is even I mean basically even more evil
it's even more evil right because you
know the natural discussion about wait a
minute minor attracted person why did we
stop saying pedophile
um is not brought forth by this term
because now the focus is on the you know
sexual desires of children
um and
it does strike me as absolutely
diabolical and that there need to be a
certain number of things just simply on
the table so that people aren't caught
off guard by this term and
um
induced to normalize it because really
we have to reject terms like this let me
just read one sentence from her piece
before you get to your main point here
again it's called next step in the war
on kids and she writes just as there are
now millions of children who believe
that you can't differentiate a man from
a woman without asking the notion that
you can't tell a child from an adult
without asking is there specific and
intentional goal here
right and by blurring this distinction
they are
legitimizing behavior that in my opinion
ought to be at the very top of our list
of things that we defend against now I
don't want to globalize too much I will
say in the last
five years I believe we have seen an
epidemic of our failure to protect
children from harm and you see it across
all sorts of domains right what we did
over covid vaccinating children who
weren't vulnerable to the disease with a
highly novel uh inoculant
was unconscionable right even if there
was no evidence of harm there was no
reason to expose them to something novel
and novel stuff hurts people and so why
would you even take that risk and it was
even worse than that because we did know
or some people knew that there were
harms that were done so
anyway my argument is going to be these
things are part and parcel of each other
now of course the failure to protect
children extends into other domains that
go back much farther right people will
have seen my two conversations with Mike
mu and they will know that by Mike Muse
model which I am all but certain is
correct evolutionarily we are allowing
uh facial structure in children who have
yet to be harmed to be degraded by
giving them diets that do not create the
proper feedbacks and that it isn't just
malocclusion the failure of the teeth to
meet properly that is caused by this but
it is many other pathologies right the
sicknesses that people have allergies
that they have sleep apnea right
potentially
um
attention deficit disorder all sorts of
pathologies that we to the extent that
Mike Mia was right which again I think
is he's almost certain to be mostly
right
um
we are we haven't yet harmed people in
the future right there may we may have
to deal symptomatically with people who
have already had this problem but you
know anybody who hasn't been born yet
could be saved from it and we're not
protecting those future children from
this problem so there's some epidemic of
failure to protect children and the
harms are
not small
right it is not a minor matter that you
get an injection that causes myocarditis
right that is a life shortening
disability the
um toying with the
uh breaching of the taboo against
pedophilia is going to expose children
to what is effectively a psychological
maiming
right that that is the thing and so
first thing I wanted to point out what
the trick is
and it's a trick we've already talked
about it a little bit uh today in a
different context but the trick is to
get people on board with some strategic
change that is desired by some group
that is advocating for something it
should not advocate for
but to get people who don't have a dog
in the fight on board by people who just
want to do the right thing right people
who want to do the right thing well how
do you do this you create the impression
that somebody is a victim
and that their victim status has to be
your focus we have to actively challenge
the victim status and in the case of
this uh adult attracted minor
victim is a child who you are oppressing
by blocking their sexual attraction to
an adult now a this is sophistry to the
nth degrees demonic software demonic
sophistic but the point is it's
obviously just garbage and the idea that
one feels an obligation to Marshal a
counter argument is already wrong right
this is insane and I want to explain why
it's insane
even if you took all of the arguments
that are made in favor of a shift like
this and you said there's truth in them
I'm not saying there is but let's say
there was
right
you still cannot be certain
that the change you are contemplating is
not going to do massive harm to many
many children who have yet to be harmed
by this in other words the precautionary
principle even taken at its you know at
its its lightest measure
still requires you to forbid us to play
with this boundary right so that you do
not end up maiming children who have yet
to be in this case psychologically
maimed by such an interaction right even
if you thought the argument was right
it's still not so certain to be right
that you can afford to play with this
definition
okay so that is me granting way more
than I should even if the argument was
right it's still Dead on Arrival in any
decent society that understands that its
top obligation has to be to protect
children from harm that hasn't happened
to them yet right that should be our top
priority and the fact that we keep
falling down on that obligation across
different domains ought to have us on
high alert we are screwing this up and
we have no right to screw it up this you
know a society that fails at this will
fail period right you don't protect the
young you're cooked
so okay now let me step back and talk
about this actual claim right because I
think
um you know it couldn't be more
ludicrous
I mean again I'm going to jump in and
say I don't like sophistry ludicrous
it's grotesque it's evil it's it's
demonic it's demonic as I as I also said
that I
I just I object
to words like ludicrous well here it's
not it's nowhere close I agree with you
now as an evolutionary biologist I will
say I try very hard to avoid claims that
something is evil because I know that
evil is a bad strategy if we take a
morality to be the absence of morality
and evil to be the desire to do harm
evil is rare because you don't get ahead
by doing it this is rare this is a bad
strategy that's that is I agree with you
if if ever there was a place where we
should invoke terms of evil this is it
so the normal caution about invoking
that too easily does not belong here
this is a place where that does belong
all right but I wanted to talk about
just the basics of the claim and point
out how insane this is I mean a it's a
little hard to know
what normal childhood looks like in this
regard because you mean anymore
no at all
right because what we're talking about
is who children are sexually attracted
to a we're not supposed to talk to them
about it B it tends to be lost in memory
because the point is it just it's a
topic
that is um
we lack information right now well I
mean didn't isn't that meant I feel like
that's missing the point
well I mean it depends it depends on how
old we're talking about but I thought
the most the more basic point is
children aren't sexual but I but this is
the problem is I don't I don't think
that that's the case I think that
um
it is inevitable given what a human
being is and how a human being is
programmed to be successful as a human
being
that all of the programs that eventually
have an adult manifestation have a
prototype version in children that then
gets refined okay and so I will just uh
this is weird but you know
I believe as far as I know I am a normal
human male right the evidence for this
is actually pretty good okay you and I
have been together for decades right
we've been married since 1998 but we've
been together for decades we have two
well-adjusted children
we have not
gotten exasperated each other and gotten
divorced right well the first but not
the second
right yeah that was a yeah needed
parentheses to unite those two things
the exasperation we have felt to each
other has not produced a divorce right
and so anyway all of those indications
are
um
I think pretty strong that uh you know I
am
Not Unusual in my adult human maleness
right
well I did a little back of the envelope
combo uh it's not gonna be more math no
it is more math and it turns out because
the math is not going so well today no I
think you'll like this okay I think you
will validate that the math is excellent
okay okay here you go um I this is this
is potentially an argument for how I
might be a little unusual um oh you're a
little unusual I have if my calculations
are correct yeah been
uh mail for something like 20
000 consecutive days not a single day of
being female anywhere in that streak
didn't wake up and we're like maybe I'm
40 female today
never never want 20
000 consecutive days all right so that's
that's quite a streak okay but other
than that quite a street going there boy
it's got to be a record
I mean right
okay so said the guy who works on
lifespan
I feel that it should be a right do you
yes I do yes um okay but that's further
evidence that you're male right that's
what I'm saying yes okay quite male okay
but here's the thing I
don't I do not know how normal my sexual
development was okay but I do remember
it's a very young person like probably
five or six right
I remember
uh being attracted to you know
20 somethings you know a teacher a
babysitter who was particularly nice
looking and kind or whatever I remember
an attraction and I know for sure it was
a sexual attraction but it was vague
completely vague I had no idea what that
was even about had no concept it was
just like you know desire of some kind
right
I don't know how normal that is I don't
know if the distinction is between males
and females it may be that females don't
normally
feel that at that age and males do but
it's not
shocking that it would be well there are
we have a word you know a word that we
have which I think you just used as well
as Crush yeah right so there there is we
do know
we do recognize
the children experience these like
fits of of
Intrigue and focus
well but I'm not even sure it just isn't
a building block that was necessary you
have to go through the abstract desire
before you desire something and you know
because we're humans and we're not
pre-programmed you know in any specific
way we are you know we build up that
over time and presumably the information
that we have access to fills in details
and frankly this is a very good reason
not to have this information you know
circulating around where kids who
shouldn't be encountering this stuff or
seeing it on the Internet or whatever
right so anyway my point is I think my
development was normal I don't know that
for sure I don't know that normal means
normal for any kid or if it's normal for
boys and not for girls I don't know yeah
but
but my point my point is
the fact that I was attracted to
sympathetic nice looking girls at that
age young women women you know not you
just have to be careful with the
language because of what you're trying
to communicate I agree but I mean you
know and the problem is you get to our
age and you you know look back at you
know young people and you it we don't
have really good terms for this young
woman is about as good as we can do here
but the point is it is not surprising
given all that we know scientifically
right
there's a reason that
um Beauty
is
concentrated at the moment at which
adulthood begins right there's a reason
for that and that has to do with the
fact that the amount of a woman's
reproductive life that is ahead of her
is maximal at that moment while she is
capable of producing offspring
not surprising that boys should be
focused on
women that age
at any age right because the point is
that's that's it's about something else
yeah I mean I
uh time here but I don't know that that
argument makes sense if you're talking
about a five-year-old no I think it
makes sense because the point is the
five-year-old is going to keep building
up some model of what sexuality is until
it's actually plausible to interact and
the point is it doesn't make sense to
keep moving I mean look I had crushes on
girls my age but that vague attraction
that I didn't know what it was at the
time was focused on something else it
was you know frankly it's about sex it's
about reproduction and so not terribly
surprising that it would have that focus
and anyway my only point is
there is no argument in the world
that those desires vague as they are in
a normal child at that age should be met
with reality that's not what they're for
right
in in which case I I see now where
you've gone
in which case this is precisely
analogous too the child who wakes up and
says I am Batman
should not be taken seriously you might
indulge in his fantasy for the day you
might let him go to school dressed as
Batman yep the child who wakes up
and who is a boy and says I am a girl
should not be taken as reality yep and
the child who has such a Feeling
towards an adult probably doesn't
announce it so it's right so you know
it's it's different and then this is
probably this is probably not something
that becomes public
but uh is part of a fantasy Escape of
development which is about the child
progressing towards adulthood and which
should not interface in any way must not
interface in any way with uh The Adult
World adults and their behavior and
adults making decisions about what they
can or cannot do with or to children
right and actually it occurs to me now
that there's another example
um I remember we were at a party at a
colleague's house I'm sure you're
allowed to tell the story yeah okay yeah
I know where you're going yeah okay I
will I will
Purge identities I don't think they're
important to the story okay
we were at uh a couple of colleagues
married to each other had a couple of
kids and we were at a a holiday party of
theirs and uh Zach I believe it was
um was I thought you were purging
identities oh Zach Zach I can I can make
it right with him later but
um anyway Zach at one point uh must have
been
he was five or six yeah he was he was
and the daughter of of one of the people
there was 14 15. yeah
um and he Zachary was um
gazing up at her sweetly sweetly but
with such a but clearly very focused on
this beautiful girl and this beautiful
girl's father looked at Zach and said
he's gonna be okay
it's true yeah anyway there's nothing
wrong with that story it's a good story
right
um yeah well you're welcome
um but uh but anyway the ah look
the whole thing I don't know how much we
know about what normal looks like yeah
but the point is don't you dare mess
with normal which involves
having thoughts to yourself never
explaining them to anybody them being
the foundation on which you're later
more precise less vague sexuality is
built right all of that is normal and
the idea that any adults at all are
playing with the concept that these
things should be brought into reality
that you know your fantasies as a child
have anything to do with what the adult
should be thinking about is insane
again insane is too gentle yeah it is it
is and so well maybe that's just the
punch line of this is
no matter what you think no matter
whether you hear an argument that you
think has some Merit no argument that
you could possibly Marshal in this space
is sufficient to overcome the burden of
what we don't know and the Damage that
we absolutely do know can come from this
right pedophilia no way right
that is that is a bright Line If ever
there was one right there is no brighter
line than that one so
um I don't know I I I hope we can wake
the up from this because watching
people experiment with linguistic
arguments to get us to flirt with
removing protections of children is just
um
it is grotesque
all right
well do you also
want to talk about another thing I could
intervene with a with a light bit of a
30 seconds of
yeah okay
um let's see I gotta just pull it up
uh this uh yeah hold on I apparently
this is recent but I don't I don't have
the date on it so I'm
I don't remember exactly when this tweet
you might show it from the CDC
you all remember the CDC right uh said
this it's not too late to get vaccinated
you can get the impacts vaccine at the
same time as your flu and code vaccines
doctor I'm gonna butcher this guy's name
Demeter daskalakis sorry encourages you
to talk to your vaccinator
about what is right for you your
vaccinator that is a great villain
identity that is a villain identity when
and so I'm not going to show you the
video it's not worth watching but it's
true he's like ask your clinic clinician
or you're a vaccinator
whether or not the impact shot is right
for you
your vaccinator the vaccinator versus
the malinformer
I know who I'm betting on
that's all that that was just that's
that's the CDC and it's again I mean it
fits it's like it's again playing with
language it's not it's not grotesque and
Evil
that particular move
right but it's a lot it's another step
in a what is becoming a portfolio that
they are engaging in of
acts that could possibly be viewed as
those things
well there is a way in which it
yeah
I do find something troubling about it
yes
um
in part uh it is
some part of me doesn't want to say this
but I do feel like that tweet will only
be read by people who have not died
suddenly and that is why they can say it
isn't too late because for some people
it is too late
um
yeah yep see math again I mean it's
underlying it's deeply enough it's
always there it is everywhere
um yeah without math life itself would
be impossible wow wow is that true
without things that we can describe with
math
yes I mean I yes fine you know the it's
there's the math and there's the thing
that we call math when we study it but
yeah I was talking about the first the
actual math so I've never nailed it down
for sure but there's this quote that is
attributed to Darwin sometimes
um a mathematician
is like a blind man in a dark room
looking for a black cat that isn't there
I know I know but I did find several
references I don't think it's Darwin and
I don't really think it's true but I do
think it's funny
that's awesome yep all right I've gone
through my process all right here we go
analogous to uh my trick for getting out
of speeding tickets oh um but you sure
you want to give this away yeah so I'd
never get pulled over anymore so
um I don't think I need it
like just inviting the universe yeah I'm
taunting the universe well it's been
taunting me so let's turn about is
I think that's true also at least not
here on the uh the uh autonomous West
Coast
um anyway my trick for not getting
tickets doesn't work every time but it
does reduce the number of tickets that
actually get written
is that as the lights go on
um you're being pulled over instead of
um trying not to get angry you
accelerate the process so that you go
through it and you're done with it by
the time you are pulled over hands at 10
and 20 on the wheel and you roll down
the window and say Yes officer how can I
help you right so you you accelerate the
emotional reaction as much as you can
including the physiological reaction
absolutely it is done so that you're
through the irritation and the rage and
the um absolutely finished before you
meet him yep and then
he or she walks up to the window and I
mean first of all you do it right okay
you find a good place to pull over and
pull over far enough so you don't leave
the officer hanging in the street you
keep your hands on the wheel so he's not
worried that you're gonna pull something
on him and you roll down the window and
you say how do you roll down the window
with your hands up yeah you wait till he
knocks somebody yeah you wait till he
comes up I'm playing at sophistry right
yeah you
you're not very good at it you're
welcome yeah awesome
um but anyway yeah at the point that you
uh display no anger whatsoever because
frankly you got it all out of your
system
um it's really clear yeah it's really
clear and the thing is it's very
unusual I think from the cops
perspective because they you know
everybody they pull over you're not
anxious right like you're you're not
exactly and so the point is that very
often causes them to think oh this
person sucks less than average and you
know
they'll throw you a bone but um
um you know I feel burned I feel I feel
singled out which is in fact exactly how
it works right exactly unless you're
alone on the highway when you get pulled
over you're going with a bunch of people
you're hardly the only one speeding
right and you know you've Justified it
didn't used to be the case anyway anyway
we digress I have now gone through this
process I'm I'm ready to engage this
last thing
um
so many of you will have noticed that uh
Sam Harris showed up
in lots of places he was trending on
Twitter for some stuff that he said and
weirdly Enough From my perspective what
he said was about me and
um
well I didn't like it all that
uh
so the question is what to do about and
I didn't mention it last week in part
because I you know did need a little
process and it was going to take longer
than pulling over to the side of the
road to get past that process uh in
order to do anything reasonable with
this but
I don't know how we ended up here
from my perspective and I
understand that there are in some sense
two planets
there's Planet what I think is planet
reality right and on planet reality I
believe Sam Harris has been wrong about
just about everything related to covid
and you and I have not been right from
the beginning but we rapidly got writer
and writer every place we got something
wrong we fixed it and we now uh have a
set of positions that is strange and
remarkable as they are to appear to be
borne out by the evidence and are very
robust okay things happen covert was
complex
guy got some stuff wrong
what I don't understand is why he's on
the offensive right why is he taking a
Victory lap why is he torturing logic in
order to rescue his rightness from the
evidence none of that makes any sense
and at some level I guess he's entitled
to do that but what he's not entitled to
do and you know look Sam among other
things is a moral philosopher
and my claim is going to be that Sam is
not entitled to be taking a Victory lap
where he has been wrong and making the
arguments that he's making if he is not
also willing to make those arguments to
me
so that we can pressure test them
now I will say there is one aspect of
this I don't know what to do I don't
know whether to feel relieved that he's
attacking me and not both of us right
like I don't want him attacking you so
maybe that's good on the other hand it
does seem kind of disrespectful
um but whatever the case is it does seem
to me that as a moral philosopher Sam
you are required if you are not going to
Simply take a breather and reflect on
how you got stuff wrong if you really
think you got stuff right
and you think that the reasoning that
explains how you got things right uh is
robust
you don't really have the right not to
talk to me about it so
either you're going to agree with that
and we're going to find some way to talk
and I promise to be decent about it I
I'm not going to pull any punches but
um I think you and I could have a
conversation we could do this IDW style
we could have you on Dark Horse and we
could talk about why you think you were
right in spite of what I think the
evidence says and we could see how those
arguments work out right that would be
in some sense the easiest thing to do
we could have somebody else like Joe
Rogan or Jordan Peterson uh moderate a
discussion between us and some since
Peterson would be a natural since I
moderated the debate between you two
right this could be a change of chairs
and we could get to some productive
thing and I think you will agree that uh
whoever is actually right
the world would benefit from us figuring
that out in a way that lots of people
could understand what it is that makes
that position correct no matter what it
is that should be true
um we could do that or as a third
possibility
we could as I suggested I guess it was
I think it was in June
um I suggested that we use the qpark
software environment which as far as I
can tell neutralizes every valid concern
you have that uh
would flow from us having a conversation
so you Sam have expressed concern for
example that if you were to sit down
with me that I might spring some study
on you that you'd never heard of or
hadn't thought deeply about and you
might fumble and that that might result
in people getting the wrong impression
and that you know lives could be lost as
a result of the fact that you didn't
know what to say in the moment and I you
will recall that when you made that
argument I said it was one of the few
things I agreed with you about that this
is a danger and that that's a problem
and so we should neutralize it but the
qpark software environment which is
still a prototype but good enough to use
completely neutralizes that concern
because it a it is asynchronous you
could
um
write out your argument and take as much
time in doing so as you wanted and you
only you know push the I don't know if
the publish button but the send button
on your argument when it's done
you would also be completely free to
bring anybody you thought was expert
along with you so that you wouldn't be
suffering from having less Insight than
you might in some area that wasn't your
your particular Focus you could bring
Eric tople whoever you wanted I will
bring my people and we can have this out
we can figure out what it is that we
disagree on what the evidence actually
suggests is true and what the
implications are for how we should be
managing the pandemic or whatever it is
so look that's three options I don't
really feel like it was required that I
give you three options but you got three
options on the table and if you don't
take any of those options if you still
think it's cool to be going on podcast
after podcast accusing me of not being
qualified to talk about things where I
have been writing you have been wrong
well then you know I'm gonna stop being
nice about this so please Sam think
about it think about it in moral terms
and get back to me because uh
you're at the end of my patience
excellent
that brings us to the end of this week's
show oh not the universe good I'm glad
to hear that definitely not we're not
there yet no we're gonna take a 15
minute break or so and come back with
answers to your questions which you can
ask at darkhorsesubmissions.com
uh we'll spend about an hour in that
live q a and then we'll be back again
next week same time same place
you can email logistical questions that
you have to Dark Horse moderator
gmail.com we've also been getting
requests lately for do you have an
address to send mail to and such
um we do and I don't remember it at the
moment but it's on both of our websites
oh we do that's the answer to the
question you could you can email that
darker's moderator gmail.com or you can
go on to either of our websites and
support button you'll find a mailing
address
please consider joining our patreons
read hunter-gatherer's Guide to the 21st
century and
most important of all
until we see you next time be good to
the ones you love eat good food and get
outside be well everyone
[Music]
thank you